Who else will join Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
in "Deadpool 3?" The Hulk? Maybe Captain
America? Here's everything we want to
see when the Merc with a Mouth returns.
When it was first announced that Hugh
Jackman would be back as Wolverine,
it may have brought about the same sense
of excitement as when actor Josh Brolin was
revealed to be taking on the role of Cable
in "Deadpool 2." While his portrayal of the
futuristic cyborg warrior was well-received,
many might have been disappointed that the
film put Cable into the role of villain for
much of its runtime. Many fans are hoping
that "Deadpool 3" producers won't be tempted to
do the same with Wolverine by pitting the Merc
with a Mouth against the old Canuckle-head,
instead making the film a true team-up.
Given the friendship between actors Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman, we don't suspect that Wolverine
will be Deadpool's enemy, though we do expect
to see at least one fight scene between the
two at some point in the film. Seeing the
two blade-wielding mutants with the fastest
healing factors slicing and dicing away at
one another will surely be a fun sight. But
if the film is smart, it will dispense with
the rivalry quickly and make Wolverine and
Deadpool fast friends, reluctant allies, and
a hard-hitting duo worthy of Jackman's return.
"We work as a team."
They may adapt a popular storyline from the
comics that saw the pair of X-Men join forces,
or invent something new for fans to get excited
about. But a proper team-up that lets us see the
actors' impeccable on-screen chemistry might be
what fans want to see most out of "Deadpool 3."
With the third "Deadpool" film now under
the Walt Disney banner it's now a realistic
possibility for us to see the inclusion
of characters from the MCU. We're not
sure if that will mean the movie will take
place within the "Avengers" universe or
see Deadpool travel through alternate
dimensions, but we fully anticipate
at least a couple of MCU cameos. But what we
want to see most is a reunion of the classic
"Avengers" team — including the returns of
Iron Man, Captain America, and Black Widow.
Though all three characters have met their end in
the MCU, this is "Deadpool" we're talking about,
a series where anything goes and nothing
has to make sense. If anything could get
Chris Evans or Robert Downey Jr. to make their
way back into costume, we could see them doing
it for "Deadpool 3," the film that convinced Hugh
Jackman to unretire and dawn his claws once again.
Whether it's for a big action sequence or a
blink-and-miss-it cameo like James McAvoy's
"X-Men" in "Deadpool 2," a reunion of "Avengers"
stars feels like the right choice. The chance for
Wolverine to meet them is the cherry on top of
the sundae. Even if it's just something silly,
a comeback for our dearly departed
heroes is what we're hoping for.
We probably speak for all fans when we say
that there's one superficial element that we
selfishly want to see for no other reason than its
sheer coolness. That element is a comic-accurate
costume for Hugh Jackman's Wolverine. It's
remarkable to think that Jackman appeared as
the character for nearly 20 years, but never wore
any kind of outfit that even vaguely resembles his
traditional comic book costume, and never
once donned his iconic winged face mask.
In the most curiously overlooked aspect of the
maverick multi-clawed mutant, fans were teased
with a possible yellow and black costume in a
deleted scene from "The Wolverine." However,
this scene was only included in the home
release of the film. Thus, audiences
missed out on seeing it in action because we
never picked up his story from that point,
with both "Days of Future Past" and "Logan" taking
place at various points across the timeline.
Of course, it would be just like Ryan Reynolds
to know this is exactly what audiences want to
see and play it for a joke, constantly teasing
a costume that never comes. But in the end,
putting Wolvie in costume is far too tempting
for the notoriously fan-loving Reynolds — and
would be too crowd-pleasing a moment
— for him not to include it. Though
we can't consider this one a lock, we think
it's more than likely the filmmakers deliver.
“You afraid you might like it?"
When it comes to match-ups between a pair
of heroes, few can top Wolverine and the
Incredible Hulk, a rivalry that began back
in Wolverine's first appearance in "The
Incredible Hulk" #181. By the late 2000s, both
characters had made their way to the big screen,
with Jackman making Wolverine famous, and
the Hulk appearing in two films of his own
before Mark Ruffalo took on the role
beginning with the superhero team-up
film "The Avengers." While rights issues have
kept the characters apart, it hasn't stopped
fans from dreaming about a showdown between
the two actors as their iconic characters.
Following Disney's acquisition of Fox, though,
fans began to wonder if their dreams could come
true, with Jackman's mutant finally coming to
blows with Ruffalo's monster. Hopes seemed dashed
when Jackman doubled down on his retirement
from the role in 2017 after the release of
"Logan." But with the Aussie actor changing
his mind and coming back for "Deadpool 3,"
we want to see the match-up finally happen,
as it could be our last chance for the Hulk
and Wolverine to meet while these two actors
are in the roles. If you ask Mark Ruffalo,
it could happen, going by his comments on
the Marvelist Podcast in 2018. He said,
"I love Hugh, and it would be cool
to do something with him. If he's
up to doing it. He's always teased Hulk
versus Wolverine would be pretty fun."
If Ryan Reynolds and writers Paul Wernick and
Rhett Rheese are looking to adapt a story from
the comics — one that saw Deadpool and Wolverine
team up — the answer is clearly "The Good,
the Bad, and the Ugly." Named after the
iconic Clint Eastwood spaghetti Western,
the 2013 storyline ran in the pages
of "Deadpool" #15 through #19. Full
of Deadpool's customary humor, it saw Wade
Wilson enlist the aid of both Wolverine
and Captain America in investigating new
information regarding the Weapon X program.
Though a movie adaptation would likely
omit Captain America, or maybe not,
now that Deadpool's under the MCU banner, it
would be easy enough to substitute the Sentinel
of Liberty with a character like Colossus or
even Cable. But while the investigation into
Weapon X could be compelling, it also could
be a little played out, having been a part
of multiple "X-Men" films. Instead, what we
really love about this story is the spark
that sets it off, as a mysterious villain is
caught repeatedly stealing Deadpool's organs.
While the Weapon X angle might be a nice
idea to get the two heroes together,
an organ-theft plot that sees
Deadpool call in Wolverine for help
seems like just the kind of sickeningly
twisted story that Reynolds would enjoy.
When the dust settled on the acquisition of 20th
Century Fox by the Walt Disney Company in 2019,
fans went into a frenzy anticipating a reboot
of the "X-Men" films and their universe within
the greater Marvel Cinematic Universe. But it's
been years now and we have yet to see anything
from the world of mutants in the MCU, with a few
exceptions, including locations like Madripoor
in "The Falcon and the Winter Soldier."
However, we may be in for a long wait,
as Marvel has revealed its plans for Phase 5
of the MCU, with no "X-Men" on the calendar
through at least 2025. But we know they're
coming eventually, so why not include a
direct reference to a new team of MCU mutants in
"Deadpool 3" to whet our collective appetites?
She-Hulk is a bit more of a longshot,
especially considering the divisive fan
reaction to the Disney+ series. But there's
been talk that She-Hulk will be making her way
to the big screen eventually, according
to The Direct. So there's no reason she
can't get a head start with an appearance in
"Deadpool 3." A longtime fourth-wall breaker,
Jennifer Walters' habit of turning
to the camera and talking directly
to the audience predates "Deadpool" in the
comics, and continues to be used to great
comedic effect in her own series. We believe
seeing them sharing the screen and arguing
over which one is going to get the audience's
attention, would be a recipe for comedy gold.
And while much of the silliness in "She-Hulk"
may not have been a hit with audiences,
her tongue-in-cheek humor could feel right at home
in "Deadpool," where a twerk or a
"bruh" might not be out of place.
"Bruh."
Plus, if we do get a Hulk/Wolverine showdown,
who better to break it up than Bruce's cousin,
who can mock the overly macho boys for always
finding a reason to fight amongst themselves?
Heading into the release of "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness," many fans were
hoping for a parade of former movie guest stars.
There were big dreams of seeing non-MCU heroes
like Nicolas Cage's Ghost Rider or Wesley
Snipes' Blade back in action across the
multiverse. There was even brief talk of
new versions of the Avengers, with rumors
swirling of Tom Cruise suiting up as Iron Man –
gossip that turned out to be entirely made up.
"Nice!"
Ultimately, though, the film limited its
guest appearances to the Illuminati in
a single key sequence, disappointing
many. But if "Deadpool" is truly going
to embrace the weirdness of being
under the Disney and MCU banners,
cameos from heroes from past movie universes
would be the perfect card to play. Admittedly
we don't want "Deadpool 3" to get bogged down
in cameos, but that doesn't mean they can't
give them to us in spades while keeping
the movie focused on a streamlined story.
After all, there's no better franchise to
utilize one-off appearances from a gaggle of
multiverse heroes than this one, where a joke
can be played for a laugh before moving on. A
cavalcade of cameos would finally fulfill every
fan's fantasies. The opportunity to have Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine finally share the screen with
the likes of Ioan Gruffudd's Mr. Fantastic — or
even Ben Affleck's Daredevil — in single-scene
gags might be too tempting to pass up.
The internet and social media have been
blowing up since the announcement that
Hugh Jackman would be back as Wolverine
for "Deadpool 3." Hordes of fans have been
assembling their wish lists of cameos and
match-ups. But in all the excitement over
the unprecedented access the filmmakers
have to any number of Marvel heroes,
we want to make sure they don't forget that
Deadpool already has an excellent supporting cast.
That's right, with all the
talk centered on Wolverine,
let's remember there are plenty of great
characters from the first two films we
want to see back in action. That includes
disgruntled cabbie Dopinder, lucky Domino,
steel-skinned Colossus, sardonic roommate Blind
Al, and the jaded Negasonic Teenage Warhead. Heck,
we might even get to see fire-starter Rusty
Collins and time-traveling mutant Cable too.
Let's face it: we want to see cameos,
but only as long as the film doesn't
get sidetracked so far that it forgets about
old favorites. Some fans might worry that so
many characters will hurt the film, but Marvel
has excelled with large ensemble casts before,
and even a solo film or two with plenty of
guests. They can watch "Captain America:
Civil War" or "Spider-Man: No Way Home"
if they want to see how to do it right.
No joke, we want to see Kevin Feige. Yes,
we mean the President of Marvel Studios,
the master of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
and the man with the famous baseball cap.
We want to see him in "Deadpool 3."
How and why, you ask? For starters,
he's the king of all things Marvel movies, and
it's long past due that the fans get a chance
to show their love. "Deadpool 3," the first
film to firmly cross over the "X-Men" and
MCU universes with a sense of good humor,
is just the right place for it to happen.
Don't forget, Marvel Comics founder Stan Lee has
had cameos in nearly every major Marvel movie,
and with his passing in 2018, maybe
Marvel can pass the torch to Feige,
the founder of the MCU. A movie that doesn't just
break the fourth wall but smashes through it could
easily see its star breaking down Feige's door
and demanding answers when he finds himself in
the MCU, unaware of Disney's purchase of 20th
Century Fox. It might even combine our wish
for an "X-Men" reboot tease with the studio head
knee-deep in franchise planning when we see him.
"That'll do!"